welcome back to drew's news a special
world kindness day edition
i know i can really get behind a day
like this
joining me is someone who is a real good
egg
he never ruffles any feathers except
maybe his own
and he's an impeccable friend to
everyone he meets
joining us now live from his nest on
sesame street
please welcome big bird
hi drew how is your morning so far
always early bird
well my day is going great here on
sesame street and
and you know the old saying the early
bird gets the bird seed
yes it does yes it does i'm tongue-tied
because i'm so excited to meet you
i have left i'm excited to meet you it's
a dream come true
and today is world kindness day
do you mind explaining what it's all
about
oh sure well i can tell you what
kindness is about you know kindness is
about
it's about showing people how much you
care
and and and you can be kind to to
animals and
and the environment too and and it makes
my friends feel good
when i'm kind to them so so that that
kind of makes me feel good you know
yes it's true i it's um
it's funny the nicer you are to people
strangely the better you feel
yourself but how do you show kindness to
your friends on sesame street
well whenever whenever i'm sad my best
friend snuffy
iggy calls me and he cheers me up and
that's really kind
and then also grover he always holds the
door
when he sees someone leaving hooper
store with a lot of groceries so
that's really kind and uh an abby
kadabby she's kind to the earth by
watering the plants in her garden and
and that's really kind and you know what
drew even oscar the grouch can be kind
he takes really good care of his pet
worm slimy
well in honor of world kindness day we
wanted to do a little sketch
we're calling kind tweets get it tweet
you know what drew i'm really great at
tweeting
yeah yeah i tweet all the time
tweet tweet tweet tweet i would love to
follow
you on twitter well we're gonna read
the kindest tweets that we found on the
internet
to spread a little happiness today big
bird are you ready
oh sure i'm ready drew okay i'm gonna go
first
um at dad of five
tweeted hashtag hero when nine-year-old
rhys
lost her home in california's biggest
wildfire
she also lost her baseball cards 100 of
them and she was heartbroken and when
kevin ashford a lifelong collector found
out
he knew what he had to do he gave her
all 25
000 of his own cards
wow
oh i love this okay big big bird tweet
tweet your neck
okay here we go this this one is from my
friend ernie
and it says for world kindness day
my old buddy burt gave me his favorite
argyle socks
to make some new sock puppets
g-bert that was really kind of you it
says
he's right okay that was so kind okay
one more tweet tweet
at the good news network tweet
seven-year-old boy who was bullied opens
a huge
food pantry making his life all about
positive energy
i love this kavanaugh bell told his mom
he wanted to start
a gofundme page to fulfill his mission
of assembling and distributing care
packages filled with food
and toiletries for his elderly neighbors
and guess what kavanaugh is here
now hello hi
hello kavanagh what an amazingly kind
person you are what motivates
your kindness and positive attitude
well i know we're all going through some
hard times right now
and i just want to make sure that people
know
that people feel happy and that they're
loved
so every day i think of how i can make
this world
a better place whether it's by
my care packs or speaking up and
speaking out against bullying
i want to show the world that being
positive is cool
yeah oh kavanagh i just i love what you
said there it's so so special
how does it feel to help out so many of
your neighbors
it makes me feel so beautiful inside
that
i get to make have people
have what they need and my goal is to
help a thousand people in my community
but
i've helped over 10 000 people not in
just my community but all over the
country
wow and kavanaugh how have the people
responded to your amazing work
well they're usually kind of surprised
and sometimes they cry happy tears
because no one has helped them
like i have but the most
awesome part is i've been able to
inspire kids up their community
like charlie my friend he's in new
jersey he's helping his community
and nicholas my other friend he
is in atlanta or you could say georgia
helping his community we are all so
impressed with you kavanagh and our
friends at
sprouts and the sprouts healthy
communities foundation
heard about what you're doing and would
like to help you
continue to spread kindness by giving
you ten
thousand dollars in healthy food
thank you so much wait look cavanaugh
here we go
[Applause]
thank you so much such a wonderful
market with such
incredible produce and healthy food and
beautiful
quality companies that they sell oh i
just
love them so much and i was so thrilled
that
they stepped up to the plate in the way
that they did all
inspired by you thank you kavanagh
thank you so much and you can catch big
bird
and the rest of his friends on the 51st
season of sesame street i even have the
collector's guide
and everyone else can watch phil
right now on hbo max we'll be right back
thank you big bird